sal and richard planned a little bit of
a cocktober surprise for us i'm not a
big fan of what they're gonna do here
it's pretty disgusting what's the event
well this might be our dumbest stunt
we've ever done it's called synchronized
pissing
similar to synchronized swimming sal and
i are going to piss to this song blue
danube which we've renamed the yellow
danube now i'm going to go first sal
goes second when you say you go first
when you hear the song you'll get what
we're saying it's a song that goes
and then i'm going to go piss piss piss
piss and then it's going to go again and
then sal's going to go piss piss piss
piss i will tell you this i know they
put hours of rehearsal and tech setup
into this that's why i'm allowing it are
you ready here i go one two three
[Music]
sal [ __ ] it up look at him stupid ass
[Music]
look south sucks
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
why are you [ __ ] it up i'm getting p
shy howard i'm i never this never
happened to me before
all right
your turn's coming up don't [ __ ] it up
here comes your turn
all right here we go i'm starting it
again richard you'll go first yep
richard you're a pro i got to say you
always come through
here comes richard
[Music]
look at him
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh douchebag
i've never been more disappointed in
[Music]
this is your whole job i can't believe
it this has never happened to me you're
the king of piss so i know
what's going through your head let me
help you out here because you know i'm
just like my whole body's
has choked up my my [ __ ] is choked up
my [ __ ] just like choked up like it just
like
stopped did you pee this morning sal
when you woke up i peed this morning
because it would have been too painful
then i immediately started drinking
howard i had like two bottles of water
in the coffee i did everything right can
i let the rest of my pee out now all
right i'll play it again let's keep one
more shot all right here we go one more
stop showing off
all right here we go can i pee one more
time howard
you suck so
he's drinking more water you're gonna oh
now he's getting desperate
richard you'll go first sal you'll go
second here we go only a shot for this
guy
[Music]
look at richard what a pro
look at the concentration
yes look at him watch him choke
nothing zero look at the blank
it face down i'm even giving more time
come on go ahead
find your pecker head
i learned how to fart nothing nothing
all right another october failure here
goes richard now here's me
[Music]
what a problem
[Music]
jesus richard
sorry i had to let it out finally
i should fire you for this sal you
should i'm disgusted with myself
i'm sorry all right i mean this this is
a huge failure for me i apologize to you
i apologize to the audience one success
and one disappointment i i think it's
this whole new world we live in
everything is backwards even you know i
love the p and my pee is the story of my
life and then for october
there's nothing more that i love than
cocktober and then i i i uh i choked
richard you're the mvp of cocktober
where do you see michelle's face well
all this is going on it's just so funny
pushing i'm just so heartbroken oh cell
had his hands up above his head like
pushed like he was in like a oh every
position i was leaning on the wall
pretending i was like in a real bathroom
i was trying to get into the mindset
so he's gonna be so mad when he finally
pees too no you know when he's gonna pee
i'm gonna tell you exactly what's gonna
happen we're gonna go off the air the
cell's gonna pee like a racehorse
tape itself
so why don't you just go work for uh
national public radio who needs you here
now
are you freaked out sal that you
couldn't pee yeah it feels like a turtle
that went back into its shell like
just panicked
yeah
i have panicked penis
my whole workspace smells like urine
right now it's like we're in hannibal
lecter's basement look at him standing
there
oh the funny thing is i've peed several
times down here already like you know
during the show i'll pee in a water
bottle down of course you're an animal
yes
he's like a dog you know he would be in
the middle of the street with people
around him
it's
next cocktober uh richard's going solo
no sal it's going to be like when simon
left garfunkel it's just going to be
awesome you know and then you're going
to go on richard to a bigger and better
career with that that's right pal you'll
just watch